hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to contempt now this is the
first game that I've been will record
since I got back to LA and I'm eager to
start on an indie horror game just
because I want to get the crap scared
out of me and I hope this is gonna
deliver now this was made by a college
student I believe anyway oh hello hi oh
boy so why did I drive out here and I'm
assuming that's my car not just two
lamps in the darkness oh boy I miss my
grandma's house grandma I'm home oh did
you miss me
I loved the chimes that you have here
they always remind me of home oh grandma
you scamp you lock this door right now
and let me in I promise I'm not scary oh
hi well okay I guess I'll just go in the
toolshed grab an axe hack my way into my
own grandma's house oh hi whew it's
quiet in this shed I don't know why but
it's quiet all right can I run no this
is the standard crawl that I'm gonna
have around my grandma's house she told
me strictly never to run runnings bell
hi hello rumbling why is it so rumbly in
here also who's that Oh sounds like
there's a storm or a train passing by
but Rob I told you to fix these floors
grandma
something tells me grandma needs to get
a maid cuz this place looks awful oh
grandma where's all those cookies you
promised me where is all the lovely
goodies okay grandma stew early to play
game hide-and-seek's why don't you just
come on out and let me enjoy what I came
here to enjoy a nice relaxing weekend
with family oh okay ah ooh I don't need
to take a bath right now oh hi grandma
this place don't look so good there's
bugs and trash in the shower I don't
know why but okay okay I'll go upstairs
[Music]
I did not just get scared by coats I was
doing my vocal exercises of screaming at
random points in my life so well my
vocal coach told me that that's the best
thing I could do for my boy Oh No
why did you scratch our grandpa's head
did you scratch our grandpa's head okay
it's just the other door all right well
this is open now which is nice I guess
clickety click clack oh let me stare
into this I'm sure this is gonna be good
boy home movies my favorite it's not
easy to spin around on your head okay
they're pointing arrows they're just oh
hi jeez I thought that was a face up
there also I like this I like these uh
parody videos here absurd objects
you mean stranger things hobo cop
wreck-it Ralph I want to watch wreck-it
Ralph
all right grandma I'm going upstairs go
get it
punky to Grandma don't get up don't get
up
haha got ya oh thanks taking deep inside
that no longer I can hide and it's
telling me once more it's time to roam
but I cannot tell the coming home right
on the horizon showing where I want to
be I travel on I don't know why I'm
standing like this but I'm very motion
sick
alright let's carry on hi okay grandma
you okay
grandma did you fall I'll help you hit
your life alert you fallen oh boy and
you can't get up oh it was this big
cycle okay oh grandma how do I open that
oh I found the coat room I think oh hey
I didn't close that hi oh okay
grandma will never find me in here was
that the attic opening no thank you I
don't want no no no no no oh I am I am
too smart to go near that door here I go
near that door
click okay hi little hijo neighbor up a
diddily diddily I go oh grandma I love
the deathly green mist you've done with
the place that's not good that's not a
good sound well that's all I say hi okay
bye
[Music]
oh-oh-oh
outside my class light doesn't work it's
like I never was it's what I always have
a good time at Grandma's house oh boy
I bet I get to go home freak ha ok okie
dokie
okely-dokely I guess ok
wow that was contempt and that was
actually awesome that was legitimately
awesome I had a great time with that
there was spooky I remember anyway so
that was contempt thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know your
thoughts down in the comments below and
whoever made this I don't exactly know
the name but and there were no credits
but just whoever made this great job you
did an amazing job with the ambience
with the experience with the creepiness
of it really really good stuff here so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]